hi and welcome to live tutoring for the
AP calculus exams provided by Khan
Academy in case you were curious I am
NOT Sal Khan my name is Dave and I first
took the AP calculus test back in 2006
and before joining Khan Academy I was an
AP calculus teacher so I'm really
looking forward to spending about the
next hour together practicing a range of
multiple choice and free response
questions now that the test is right
around the corner on May 9th and so we
hope that this tutoring session will be
as helpful as possible and today we're
going to go in-depth on one topic
analyzing graphs of functions and their
derivatives this is a topic that's on
the a B and BC test so it should be
helpful for anybody taking an AP
calculus test this year but the items
that we'll look at all come from the a/b
exam good news you will not need a
calculator to work out the problems
today but I do recommend that you have
something to write with and a piece of
paper so that you can follow along as we
go and just a plug for our website after
the session is over don't forget that
you can go to Khan Academy org and we
have over 500 videos exercises and
articles for the a/b exam and nearly 600
for the AP Calculus BC exam including
video explanations for two full free
response questions sections okay
so let's get started this first section
we're actually going to take about five
to ten minutes to review the key
concepts that we'll be going over today
so if you haven't already grab something
to write with it will be helpful to have
these notes to look back on when we
start the multiple choice questions
let's take a look
this first graph and I'll zoom in a
little bit so that it's hopefully easier
to read let's review how we would
interpret if this were a graph of the
original function f so this is the most
straightforward because we can say that
this original section right here at the
beginning it's going up and so we can
say it's an increasing interval and
similarly here at the end we have
another increasing interval all right
starting simple and in the middle we
have a decreasing interval here in the
color red what else can we conclude when
we're looking at a graph of the original
function f we can say that this point up
here at the top is a relative relative
maximum so the highest point in that
section of the graph it's a relative
maximum and down here opposite we have a
relative minimum relative minimum what
else well if we look at the curvature or
the concavity this first section of the
graph right here we can say it is
concave down concave down and maybe it's
a little cheesy but I like to write it
like this instead of the letter n to
remind myself that that section any part
of general parabola shape in that part
is concave down and up here we have
concave up concave up again I can use a
curve instead of the letter U and last
this point in the middle where the
concavity switches it looks like it's
the origin on this graph is our point of
inflection should be a familiar term to
you by this point in the year we'll
label it as our point of inflection so
on this graph it's the most
straightforward when we're looking at a
graph of F what you see is pretty much
what you get you can interpret it
literally but now we're going to take a
look at a second graph and it will look
exactly the same
first same shape but this time we're
going to label it as f Prime graph of
the first derivative of F how would we
interpret this graph well now we would
say that up here where F prime is
greater than zero that gives us
information about the original function
f it tells us that the original function
f was increasing during those intervals
was increasing during those intervals so
even though this section if we look at
it visually is decreasing because this
is a graph of f prime that tells us that
the original function f was decreasing
in that interval or was increasing in
that interval and down here we have
opposite we have F prime is less than
zero and we can say that that means that
the original function f was decreasing
right what other information can we
identify from this graph we've got these
interesting points where we have a
transition in between a negative F prime
value and a positive F prime value or
vice-versa and so let's think about this
first one right here that's where the
original function f switched from
decreasing so I were visualizing it down
here it was decreasing and then we had a
moment where it hits a slope value of
zero and then it switches to a positive
value of f prime and starts increasing
and so that moment where we had a
transition is our relative minimum our
relative minimum right there and there's
another point on here that also appears
that that same characteristic this last
one over here another relative
abbreviate relative min but our middle
point is the opposite it actually
switches from F increasing a positive
value of f prime to decreasing a
negative value of f prime so that point
where it switches from a positive value
to a negative value is our relative
maximum and it looks like we have a
question coming in from YouTube asking
about the difference between relative
and absolute minimums and maximums we'll
get into that difference later as we
look at the free response questions but
the short answer is that a relative
maximum is the highest value within an
interval of the function but it may not
be the highest value overall there could
be an endpoint that reaches a higher
value okay so now we've looked at the
graph of f prime when we've also looked
at the graph of the original function f
will finally look at a graph of the
second derivative F double prime will be
the same shape
we'll see what information we can find
from that graph let's take a look here
we go f double prime I hope you're able
to record this at home on a piece of
paper so that you can look back on it
this first section up here where the
second derivative is positive tells us
that the original function f was concave
up concave up and down here where the
second derivative is negative the
original function f was concave down
concave down
and just like the last graph there are
these three interesting points here
where the second derivative value is
neither positive nor negative
it's zero and as a switch a transition
in sign so what happens when the second
derivative switches sign the second
derivative switches sign those three
points on here are all points of
inflection all points of inflection so
we have one two three points of
inflection for this function and unlike
with a maximum or a minimum there's no
different vocabulary term for when it
switches from negative to positive as
from positive to negative they are all
equally a points of inflection all right
well before we move on the multiple
choice let's take a look there is
another question coming in from YouTube
it asks can you identify a point of
inflection on the graph of f prime the
first derivative graph so that's a good
question that comes up often and we'll
take a look back here at this graph
because we did mention points of
inflection for the other two graphs but
we didn't talk about them here at all
and the key thing to remember for that
is that the second derivative is the
same thing as the slope of the first
derivative second derivative is the same
thing as the slope of the first
derivative we just mentioned that a
point of inflection occurs when the
second derivative changes sign so we can
also say that a point of inflection
occurs when the slope of the first
derivative changes sign and we're
looking here at a graph of the first
derivative so if we ask ourselves where
does the slope change sign where does
the slope change sign and right here in
a big grey circle the slope changes sign
from a positive slope to a negative
slope
and again down here the slope of f prime
changes sign so those two points all
abbreviate point of inflection we can
identify the point of inflection from a
first derivative graph great okay so
that wraps up the notes the concept
review section the next thing that we're
going to do is look at eight different
multiple-choice questions like I
mentioned all of these questions come
from past AP Calculus a B exams and I
encourage you to kind of keep track of
how you're doing at home you can maybe
tally how many of the eight you think
you would have been able to get correct
on your own and you can identify the
problems that were especially difficult
for you on the first problem I'll walk
through the answer but on the second one
I'm going to stall a little bit move a
little bit slower so that you have a
chance to work ahead and solve it before
me let's take a look at the first
problem now this is from the two
actually from the 1998 exam before most
if not all of you were born and let's
read the problem the graph of F is shown
in the figure above which of the
following could be the graph of the
derivative of F well before we even look
at the answer choices I'm going to zoom
in on this original graph and let's
think about what we know the derivative
graph would need to look like so this
first section here is increasing F is
increasing and that tells me that the
derivative graph will need to have a
positive Y value the graph of F prime
will need to have a positive Y value in
that section so I'm going to create this
little blue box right there telling me
that it will need to have a positive Y
value and on the second half here where
we have a decreasing interval the graph
of f prime will need to have negative Y
values
and then we have this moment at the top
where the slope is zero for an instant
and the graph of f prime will need to be
zero there as well the graph of f prime
will need to be zero there also okay
with that in mind let's take a look at
the five answers so we're looking for
positive zero than negative C I want to
be able to see all five at once positive
zero and then negative so it looks to me
like we have some that clearly don't
work there's no negative section here
this one C gets it backwards and D is
just wrong in almost each section hard
to know where to start with D but we do
have two contenders a and E because they
both start out positive have a moment
where it's zero derivative value of zero
and then negative how are we going to
choose between the two well if we think
about what E is saying he is saying that
the very beginning of the graph has the
largest positive derivative we would
expect then that the original function
would be increasing at its steepest rate
right there if he were correct the
original graph would be increasing at
its steepest rate but in fact at the
beginning the graph is nearly flat it is
barely increasing and so we can say that
a matches that because a has a small
positive derivative and it reaches its
largest value somewhere in the middle of
this first interval which is where we
have our steepest section in the
original graph that's why we can say
that a in this case is the correct
answer
and not e okay so let's look at a
similar question another multiple-choice
question and this time like I mentioned
I'm going to read it a little slower
it's intentional I'm trying to give you
time to solve the problem on your own
and see if it makes sense to you so
number two I know it says 11 you can
ignore those numbers the second multiple
choice problem for us the graph of a
function f is shown above which of the
following could be the graph of f prime
the derivative of f and going to stall
for another 10 seconds if you don't have
something to write with
at least say in your head which leather
answer choice you think is correct or
you could type it in the chat box and
argue with other people for a second
about if it's a or B or E or C or D and
now let's take a look well the first
section is increasing positive
derivative value the last section is
also increasing positive derivative
value the middle segment is decreasing
so it should be a negative Y value on
the graph of f prime if I look to see
which answer has that same set up only
answer choice B matches that one and in
this case answer choice B is correct so
how did you do were you able to get that
one no problem if so great job if not
there's plenty of other practice
problems like this on our website so
that you can get the hang of it you know
the AP calculus test one of the nice
things about it is it's pretty
predictable what types of questions are
going to be coming up on the test and so
you will be very likely to see a
question that connects the graph of the
original function with the derivative
and I hope that when you see it you'll
approach that question with complete
confidence let's take a look now at a
slightly different type of multiple
choice problem the graph of a twice
differentiable function f is shown in
the figure above which of the following
is true so instead of asking us to
compare two different graphs we're asked
to order the values of F
Prime and F double Prime the X value of
one from least to greatest well let's
start with remembering that this is the
graph of the original function and so f
of one is the y-value right here so we
can say that that's zero what about the
derivative value at one well there's no
way we can actually calculate the
precise slope at that value because we
don't have the function in front of us
but we can say with certainty that the
value of F Prime at one would be
positive greater than zero because the
graph has a positive slope at that value
1 and second derivative we also can't
calculate the value but we can say that
this graph is concave down
remember it's part of a general n shape
it's concave down so it's negative at
that point and so we have one value
equal to zero one value that's positive
one value that's negative if we arrange
those from least to greatest we'd end up
with the second derivative at 1 less
than the original function at 1 both
less than the derivative first
derivative function at 1 and that
matches up with answer choice D ok let's
look at the second question in this pair
and this is very similar to the last
question but I'm going to read it a
little bit slower
take a look there's one key difference
between this problem and the last
problem so don't approach it exactly the
same way but see if you're able to get
it correct without any help from me the
graph of a differentiable function f is
shown above if H of x equals the
antiderivative from 0 to X of F of T DT
which of the following is true so let me
give you some time to think about how
you would approach that and injustice
few seconds I'll start working it out
you can chat in the box about which
answer you think is correct and see if
you're able to get this one okay so
first let's think about what's different
the difference is that this time we're
asked to evaluate H of six but that's
actually the antiderivative from zero to
six of the graph we're looking at so H
of six equals the antiderivative zero to
six the definite integral from zero to
six and when we look at the graph and we
think about the definite integral value
from zero to six although we can't
calculate the exact value of that
accumulated quantity we know that it
will be negative because all of that
area is below the horizontal axis so we
can say that it's going to be less than
zero because all of the area is below
the horizontal axis the x axis what
about the derivative H prime of six that
will be equal to f of 6 at that point
right here and we know F of 6 from
looking at the graph is equal to zero
last the second derivative is the same
thing as the first derivative of F F
prime of six so here we're thinking
about the slope at this value six and
the slope there is positive so if we
arrange those from least to greatest it
actually goes an order this time we have
H of six be negative H prime of 16 0 H
double prime of 16
positive answer choice a how did you do
did you find that one easy medium
difficult I hope it wasn't too bad
okay so we've got four multiple choice
problems done the next four we're going
to go maybe a little bit quicker and
each one will be a little bit different
than the other one and so for each one I
encourage you to work a little bit
faster than me and to try them on your
own before hearing me say the answer all
right
so question five zoom in make it easier
to see the graph of the derivative F
prime is shown above 4 negative 2 is
less than or equal to F X is less than
or equal to 5 on what intervals is f
increasing go ahead type in your answer
write it down on paper or just say it in
your head and let's take a look so the
common mistake is to look at intervals
where the graph itself is increasing but
remember that we're looking at a graph
of f prime and as we said in the initial
notes when F prime is greater than zero
that's when the original graph F is
increasing and so keeping that in mind
we can say that this whole interval from
negative 2 all the way to positive 3 is
the interval where F is increasing B is
the correct answer for this problem now
depending on how you interpret the
question you might have thought that
they would split it up into two
intervals from 1 negative 2 to 1 and
then from 1 to 3 because we do have that
moment where the derivative equals 0 but
that wasn't an answer choice and so we
know that the best answer is B from
negative 2 to 3 okay number 6
the graph of the derivative of a
function f is shown in the figure above
the graph has horizontal tangent lines
at x equals negative one x equals one
and x equals three at which of the
following values of x does f have a
relative maximum okay so a relative
maximum you can say that a relative
maximum occurs when the derivative
function switches from positive to
negative because that's where the
original function f goes from increasing
to decreasing switches from positive to
negative so here we have positive here
we have a switch from positive to
negative it's kind of weird because it
looked like it was more like 3.95 like a
little bit before 4 but the closest and
best answer here is going to be 4 only
alright for only if it was asking about
relative minimum on the other hand then
negative 2 only would be the best choice
for that we have two more multiple
choice questions right the graph of y
equals f of X is shown in the figure
above on which of the following
intervals are the first derivative
greater than zero and the second
derivative less than zero it's helpful
to see problems that have this other
derivative notation Leibniz's notation
even though the more common one that
you'll see on the AP test will be
Lagrange's nor notation but if we were
to read this problem again and instead
of reading how i just said it let's
interpret it a little bit in an easier
way so that when we look at the graph we
know what to look for so the set the
last sentence of the problem says on
which of the following intervals is the
original function increasing
and concave down increasing and concave
down
okay so we can tell clearly that the
graph is increasing here from A to B and
from B to C and then we can also say
that the graph is concave down from B to
C and from C to D and the only section
the only interval where it is both of
those two things increasing and concave
down is the interval from B to C and so
because it needs to be both we have that
conjunction and in there we're going to
select two only for this problem all
right now I know there's a lot of
questions in the comments asking about
other topics whether it's related rates
or optimization or Taylor series and all
of those are concepts that we would love
to review but given just one hour we're
going to focus on graphical derivatives
and so when hour is over go ahead and
look up those topics on Khan Academy to
watch the videos and exercises that we
have related to the AP material for
those concepts let's take a look at one
last multiple-choice question the graph
of the function f is shown in the figure
above for which of the following values
of X is the derivative F prime of X
positive and increasing positive and
increasing so f prime of X positive that
means that the graph that I'm looking at
should have a positive slope positive
slope so that would be here and here so
it's either going to be C or E but F
prime of X needs to be increasing that
means that the second derivative is also
positive
the slope of the value of f prime is
positive and so that would be where the
graph is concave up concave up would
narrow it down to just point e at Point
C we are concave down answer choice E
for that one is correct
this one actually have a small
percentage of people got it correct on
the actual AP test it appears simple at
first but recognizing that F prime of X
increasing is referring to the second
derivative and being concave up was the
key reason I think why a lot of people
mistakenly got this question wrong okay
that wraps up the multiple choice
section so there are eight problems I
hope you're able to tally up how you did
overall on those eight and I hope that
you have more confidence when you see
problems related to graphical
derivatives on the upcoming test we now
have time to go over two free response
questions and will actually be writing
out full answers here so that we can see
how we would have scored out of the nine
points available on a free response
question so let's take a look at the
first free response this is from the
2015 exam two years ago the figure above
shows the graph of f prime the
derivative of a twice differentiable
function f on the interval from negative
3 to 4 the graph of F prime has
horizontal tangents at negative 1 1 & 3
the areas of the region's bounded by the
x-axis and the graph of F prime on the
intervals negative 2 to 1 and 1 to 4 are
9 and 12 respectively Part A find all
x-coordinates at which F has a relative
maximum give a reason for your answer so
I don't know how you all compared to the
students I used to have but many of them
when we were doing practice problems
would say oh yeah I'll know how to give
a reason when it's the actual test but
in these practice problems I'm just
going to write
my answer but for today's tutoring let's
actually practice writing the reason we
would provide for the test so that we
can see if the language we use would
meet the AP standards so a relative
maximum give a reason for your answer
well we can remember that a relative
maximum is where the derivative F prime
switches from positive to negative and
that on this graph occurs at negative
two so our relative maximum would be
negative two let's practice writing in
our full answer though F prime of X
changes from positive to negative at x
equals negative two you can say
therefore this is a abbreviation for
therefore like in conclusion the
original graph F has a relative max at x
equals negative two so how was this
problem scored on the test this was two
points the first point you got for
getting the correct answer of negative
two and the second point was for
providing your reason and the common
mistakes that we see from students are
using vague language like the graph
changes from positive to negative
instead of identifying which graph were
referring to f prime of X so we want to
avoid using vague words like the graph
or the slope a second mistake was not
referencing the
this value our this graph of F Prime and
instead always just referring back to
the original function so that was two
points let's take a look at Part B now
Part B says on what open intervals
contained in the interval from negative
3 is less than X is less than 4 is the
graph of F both concave down and
decreasing concave down and decreasing
okay so concave down and decreasing well
decreasing is going to occur when the
derivative F prime is less than 0 so I'm
going to highlight in blue all the
spaces where the original function was
decreasing concave down concave down is
going to happen when the derivative
function and let me switch colors here
to make it a little bit easier Dougray
when the aridity function f prime is
decreasing like a negative slope of f
prime that tells us that the second
derivative will be negative and so f is
concave down so what's the key reason
why people made mistakes on this problem
so I'm writing out a little more detail
and this graph is decreasing let's look
in that blue section because that is the
only candidates for the final answer so
we have here from negative 2 to negative
1 and we also have from 1 to 3 from 1 to
3 those two segments from negative 2 to
negative 1 and from 1 to 3 are both
decreasing and concave down on the graph
of F and so writing in our answer we can
write it just in one sentence but we
have to use as precise of language as we
can so f you can kind of copy the
language they use in actual question
f is both concave down and decreasing F
is both concave down and decreasing on
the intervals and we saw them right
above it was from negative 2 to negative
1 and from 1 to 3 and for our rationale
we can say because the derivative
function is decreasing that's how we
knew it was concave down and negative so
we know F was decreasing there on these
intervals
this was another two-point problem one
for getting the correct intervals and
another one for having the correct
rationale and I just want to say again
that F prime decreasing was our
rationale for concave down and then we
knew the original function was
decreasing because f prime was negative
so those two parts are the corresponding
rationale for the two criteria we were
looking at if we think about common
mistakes here again students were able
to identify the intervals but many of
them struggled to express the reason for
it and oftentimes they did not say which
graph or the slope or derivative they
were referring to so get in a good habit
of always writing F or F prime or F
double Prime instead of writing the
graph all right let's take a look now at
Part C of this problem and Part C is
I'll reproduce the graph so it's a
little bit easier and cleaner for us to
look at it again so Part C is a two
point
again and it says find the x-coordinates
of all points of inflection for the
graph of f give a reason for your answer
now we talked actually because one of
you brought up a question about how to
identify the points of inflection from a
graph of f Prime and so see if you
remember and if you can identify the
points of inflection and a rationale for
them so in about 10 seconds I'll jump in
but see if you can guess how many points
of inflection there are on the graph of
F and the one sentence you might use to
justify it
all right so what do we think how many
points of inflection are there going to
be a point of inflection is going to
occur where the first derivative graph
changes sign first derivative and I
should say the slope of the first
derivative changes sign that is a point
of inflection we have that in our notes
from the beginning of the session will
reproduce it here and that happens at
negative one it happens again at
positive one and for the last time at
positive three so there are three points
of inflection on this graph and we can
write that here that F has a point of
inflection at x equals negative 1 x
equals 1 and x equals 3 because
f prime changes from decreasing to
increasing changes from decreasing to
increasing at negative 1 & 3
and opposite we have F prime changes
from increasing to decreasing at x
equals one so it is a bit of writing
it's tempting to just abbreviate and
write just a really short justification
but then we run the risk of not being
specific enough and losing out and what
could have been guaranteed points okay
so there's a Part D to this problem but
the Part D doesn't relate to the concept
we're going over today good news though
is that we do have a video on our
website that explains the answer to Part
D and so just look up the AP Calculus a
B videos and this is from the 2015 exam
ok the last free response question that
we'll go over today is from the 2013
exam let's take a look the figure above
shows the graph of f prime the
derivative of a twice differentiable
function f on the closed interval zero
is less than or equal to X is less than
or equal to 8 the graph of f prime has
horizontal tangent lines at x equals 1 x
equals 3 and x equals 5 the areas of the
region's between the graph of f prime
and the x axis are labeled in the figure
the function f is defined for all real
numbers and satisfies the condition f of
8 equals 4 there's a lot of information
I assume will use all of it eventually
but let's take a look at Part A find all
values of X on the open interval 0 is
less than X is less than 8 for which the
function f has a local minimum justify
your answer we've seen several problems
both multiple choice and free response
where we're asked to identify a local
Optima from a graph of F prime and so
hopefully you're becoming really
confident on how to do problems like
this but a local minimum as a reminder
occurs
when f-prime switches from negative to
positive and that occurs on this graph
at the value x equals 6 so if we write
our justification and one sentence is
always nice we can say x equals 6 is the
only point it's the only point where F
prime changes sign from negative to
positive
so f the original function f has a local
minimum we want to directly answer the
question they asked F has a local
minimum at x equals 6 this was just one
point out of the full nine points so you
had to get the answer and the
justification to get the one point
oftentimes the first part of a question
is the quickest and so we want to get
through it so we can move on to the
other parts of this problem okay
let's take a look at Part B then Part B
says determine the absolute minimum
value of f on the closed interval from 0
to 8 justify your answer and one of you
asked earlier about the difference
between relative and absolute and so now
we have a chance to talk about it so
first when we think about absolute
minimum value we want to identify the
candidates there are three suspects for
the absolute minimum it could be based
on Part A the relative minimum that we
found at 6 a relative minimum value
could end up being the absolute value as
well but the other candidates are the
endpoints in this case this is x equals
0 and x equals 8 so those 3 points are
the candidates we can say candidates
want to lay out our logic when you write
our answer and the first piece of that
logic is the three x values that we're
considering are x equals 0 x equals 6
and x equals 8 now we have to actually
find the value of f at each of those
three values to see which one is the
minimum value the easiest one is f of 8
and the reason it's the easiest and I'm
going to zoom out a little bit the
reason it's the easiest is because they
told us f of 8 equals 4 in the problem
so I can say F of a equals four I know
that value if four ends up being lower
than the other two values then four will
be my minimum value but let's find f of
six
so f of six if we look at this graph
over the value B right here
well we know that f of 8 is equal to
four and now we have to kind of go
backwards on this graph and undo this
accumulated quantity of seven and when
we go backwards that area is really
going to be treated as negative by the
properties of definite integrals and so
we can kind of think of it as four and
we're going to be subtracting that seven
how would we write out our justification
for that though we'd have F of 6 equals
the initial value of f of 8 plus the
integral from 8 to 6 of f prime of X DX
that's a little bit strange though to
have the bounds of integration with the
larger number on the bottom and so
that's where I mentioned that since
we're switching the order and we would
want to think about it from 6 to 8 when
we switch those bounds of integration it
becomes negative the sign changes so we
have F prime of X DX and now we can
write out that it would be 4 and this
quantity right here from 6 to 8 was 7 so
we have 4 minus 7 and we have negative 3
then for that value okay so that is
lower than F of 8 so so far the absolute
minimum value may be negative 3 but the
last one we need to test out is f of 0 f
of 0 we can use the same process as f of
6 but this time we have to go back
through for different segments so we
have minus 7 so we're moving from right
to left in this case we have well this
would be a positive 3 a negative 6
and a negative 2 negative 7 positive 3
negative 6 negative 2 if we think of all
four of those together we have negative
12 4 and negative 12 we have our initial
value of 4 then we have negative 12 so
it looks like that will be the minimum
value to write out our rationale you can
follow similar pattern as we did for f
of 6 8 0 f prime of x DX if we switch it
then to negative because we're reversing
the bounds of integration
you still have oh there is a type of
there f of 8 there we go and we have 4
then and minus 12 for a value of
negative 8 so we've written quite a bit
this problem is a lot more work now we
have to think about what our actual
answer is going to be is our answer
going to be 0 as our answer going to be
negative 8 if we reread the problem it
says determine the absolute minimum
value of F it doesn't say determine the
x value where that minimum value happens
and so in this case we want to report
out the actual minimum value negative 8
and we don't need to say the x value so
we can save them and running out of
space here so I'm going to write it
right up here in this box my final part
of the answer the minimum value absolute
minimum value
on the interval from zero to eight is
negative eight this was a three point
problem the first point comes from
laying out the candidates the second
point comes from finding the answer
negative eight and the third point comes
from your justification so the math that
we wrote where we calculated the answers
these parts in the middle and the main
mistakes on this problem were
accidentally writing x equals zero as
the final answer so the x value instead
of the actual minimum value of negative
8 so reread the problem as it was
written right before you write your
final answer to see did they ask for the
x value the minimum value or the
coordinate pair where the minimum value
occurs and that will make sure that
you're able to format your answer
correctly so we have two more parts Part
C and Part D we're almost done we have a
little less than 10 minutes left so
we're almost through Part C so looking
here let me see if I can erase some of
this work up here make it easier to read
all right same graph I've copied it here
so that's easier for us to see what open
intervals contained and 0 is less than X
is less than 8 is the graph of F both
concave down and increasing both concave
down and increasing explain your reason
this is very similar to the problem
Part B on the last free response so our
confidence should be higher take a few
seconds to think through and if you have
time you can type in what your answer
would be in the box on the screen or you
can write it down on your paper
whichever is more convenient where is it
concave down and increasing okay so
increasing is going to be anytime that
the derivative is positive so I'm going
to highlight in blue
all of the parts where the derivative is
positive which is almost all of this
graph like everything except for that
section from what is that 4 to 6 the
rest of it f prime is positive so the
original graph f was increasing but
where is the graph of f concave down F
will be concave down when F prime is
decreasing F prime is decreasing so that
if I show that in red we have from 0 to
1 and we have from 3 to 4 and it is also
decreasing from 4 to 5 but that wasn't
part of our original interval where the
graph was the value of F prime was
positive so that's not going to be part
of our final answer and so those
sections that are both blue and red are
the final answer and we'll write it in
right below you can do it in one
sentence we have F is concave down and
increasing on the first interval was
from 0 to 1 you can see up here from 0
to 1 and from 3 to 4 and for our
rationale we can say because F prime is
let's see it was decreasing and positive
decreasing and positive on these
intervals great it's a two-point
question one for the answer one for the
justification the main mistake actually
on this problem was that students were
able to find where the graph was
increasing they were able to find where
the graph was concave down but many of
them wrote those two answers separately
instead of finding only the parts that
had both characteristics like the
intersection of those two sets okay we
had the last problem this one's kind of
a challenge problem it doesn't relate as
directly to the rest of the material
we've looked at today but it's a good
challenge to end with Part D the
function G is defined by G of x equals f
of X cubed if F of 3 equals negative 5
over 2 find the slope of the line
tangent to the graph of G at x equals 3
well the first challenge in this problem
like in many calculus problems is just
clearly identifying what it's asking for
it's asking for the slope of the line so
we can guess that we're going to be
taking a derivative on this problem and
it's asking at a specific value x equals
3 so our first step then is to try to
take the derivative of G of X the
derivative of G of X derivative of G of
X well here we have f of X cubed so we
have an outside function the cubed and
we also have an inside function f of X
and so this is going to require more
than just the basic power rule this is
actually a probably can guess this is a
chain rule problem and one of the most
common mistakes was not recognizing that
this would be a chain rule problem so
using the power rule we take the outside
derivative 3 keep the inside function
the same f of X reduce the power to 2
and afterwords multiply by the
derivative of the inside function f
prime of X and we can write as a
reminder what did we just do that was
the
[Music]
and now let's put in three four all of
these values of X we've got F of three F
prime of 3 ok now we have to figure out
what F of three and F prime of three are
so these two that I'm underlining in red
we have to somehow figure out those
values the first ones given to me right
here F of three equals negative five
halves that one's good to go but what
about F prime of 3
well we haven't even looked at the graph
at all yet that graph we were given at
the start of the problem that was the
graph of F prime so it gives me the
value at 3 it tells me that F prime of 3
is equal to 4 right there so that's how
the graph came in handy for this last
part of the problem we can say that that
is equal to 4 and from here it's an
algebra problem we have to square
negative 5 halves that becomes let's see
25 over 4 and then we have to multiply
by 4 and finishing off the algebra we
have let's see divided by 4 x for
inverse operations we'll be left with
just 3 times 25 or 75 that was a 3 point
problem actually two of the 3 points
came from just calculating the form of
the derivative so just by using the
chain rule and only one point came from
the rest of the work we did in finding
the final answer and the key mistakes on
this problem were one not using the
chain rule as we mentioned and the
second mistake that we saw was mistakes
on the algebra so maybe making a mistake
in squaring the value of negative five
halves
remember if you type that into your
calculator you forget to put in
parentheses it may tell you negative
twenty-five over four so when we're
rushing we may make algebra mistakes
that that mess up our final answer
okay so it's 458 thank you for sticking
with me for the full hour I want to go
over some final tips that we went
through and then we'll be done so the
first tip is when you're looking at
problems with graphs always ask yourself
right at the start is this a graph of F
F prime or F double Prime have that
guide your thinking for the rest of the
time the second tip we mentioned this a
few times is to use precise language
never just write slope
graph or derivative instead always
replace it with something like the slope
of F or the derivative of F prime so
that the reader knows exactly what
you're talking about
since they won't be there to ask you any
follow-up questions the third one is
beware of the difference between
positive and increasing and we've used
both of those terms frequently
throughout this hour and so it was kind
of a good reminder that they mean
different things depending on which
graph we're looking at and last is to
analyze the original graph before you
take a look at the answer choices and
that will help you more quickly
eliminate wrong answers now just to make
you feel a little more confident that
last problem we did was nine points on
the AP test the average score was just
over two point five out of nine so even
if it seemed difficult and even if you
think I would have only had three or
four points on that you would have still
been above the average AP test taker all
right so that's all we have for today
thank you for joining don't forget to
check out our website Khan Academy where
you can do hundreds of more practice
problems and watch other study videos
keep up the effective practice I wish
you the best of luck on May 9th and from
all of us here at Khan Academy goodbye
for now
you